welcome to the weekly poll your number
one source for comic book discussions
I'm Benny from comic story in that's
your cue okay what's going on what's
going on guys this is Rob I'm from
Marvel explain all right all right so
the whole basis of this podcast is to
have a mishmash of Marvel DC because
Benny's a DC guy I'm an awful guy and
Dave is in between he likes both so we
figured we mixed this up and we bring
like topics on on D we figured we would
bring topics on DC and Marvel and talk
about both of them like films and all
different kinds of stuff and like her
and Vincent and comic so we're gonna
start this first half with DC Comics and
we're gonna talk about the whole forever
evil storyline which I know nothing
about but Benny does so on matters of DC
I defer to Vinnie in the beginning I'm
gonna make this really quick because if
you really want to know the entirety of
the story just need to go to my channel
to watch the videos but the whole entire
forever evil event starts with the new
52 flashpoint relaunching event what
happened is in flashpoint flash went
back in time trying to save his mother
from being killed which is like what are
the basis of the flash character and he
changed all of the timelines and made
this really crazy time where basically
Bruce had died Thomas became Batman
what's at the Amazonians and the
Atlanteans were at war
Superman had never been found he was an
underground being held by the army crazy
world known as flashpoint well when when
the flash went back in time to fix all
of these issues what he did was he
corrected it but at that point we had a
character known as Pandora who showed up
and said that she's going to merge all
of the DC timelines which you know
basically was like they they they
basically implied vertigo and they the
John Constantine stuff and wild cats and
all that stuff all that stuff got merged
into one big timeline they kind of
showed everything around there and they
made the new 52 timeline and the basis
of this timeline is everything has
happened in the last five years and
stuff like the Justice League haven't
met and Batman's events are vol kept
going it was really confusing but what
it boils down to is we had an entire
relaunch of the entirety of the universe
okay all the key events that they wanted
to keep in continuity stayed there but
for the most part all the junk events
they were thrown at the window move
forward a little bit to the meeting of
the Justice League when the Justice
League met they they were brought
together to fight against a dark side
dark side I don't know how much of DC
you know but Darkseid is one of the big
big villains and he has these things
called boom tubes that allow him to
connect various planets to each other
for instant travel that's how we always
invasor than how the Justice League
always has to stop him well the Justice
League started messing with the boom
tubes to stop Darkseid by messing with
the boom tubes they somehow linked into
the multiverse and the multiverse
allowed them to bring in the outsider
anatomica from Earth 3 the outsider is
the Alfred Pennyworth version of Earth 3
so basically like an evil Alfred
so while this was going on we had atomic
gun Alfred basically trying to set up
the return of their Justice League the
crime syndicate so then we moved to the
event of the Trinity war this was them
this was all of the stuff that they've
been setting up for the last two years
of the new 52 that basically lead into
the Trinity war things opened up with
Superman basically getting sick we don't
know why he's sick but he's like a
horribly sick and everybody wants to
blame everybody for it so we have the
Justice League versus Justice League of
America versus Justice League dark
they're all fighting and what they all
think the reason behind this is is
Pandora Pandora the girl who started the
entirety of the new 52 has Pandora's Box
and the thought process is is that
because Pandora tried to have Superman
open Pandora's box that's why he's sick
so everybody's fighting for Pandora's
Box every time you touched an Pandora's
box your greatest evils come out and you
become like the evil version of yourself
then they started getting an evil Wonder
Woman and evil Shazam everybody starts
going crazy
the original sins are coming out and
starting to mess with everyone see it's
kind of funny because they calm the
original sins in like really early in
the plotline and then we have the Marvel
event but that's like what that a minute
so basically everyone's fighting over
Pandora's box now this is one of the
complaints to have about it and what
happened it's it's all being put off as
a supernatural event Pandora's box is
supernatural well what happens is
eventually everyone's fighting over it
the whole box explodes everyone's being
decimated I think everyone's just going
crazy and the outsider anatomica show up
and they open Pandora's box and they
explain that Pandora's box is actually
from Earth
it is used as a boom tube tour portal to
earth 3 and the only people who can open
Pandora's box are people from Earth 3
that's why they can just touch it by
touching it basically you take on like
potential poor parts of the personality
of the people from Earth 3 that's why
everyone was turning evil so they open
up the the boom tube earth threes just
as they comes through and that leads us
to forever evil forever evil is the
crime syndicate has now come from Earth
3 onto our planet and the first thing
they do is because basically Superman is
already out of the picture because he's
still sick we find out the reason why
he's sick is because atomic could put a
sliver of kryptonite in his brain she
can shrink down to like microscopic size
went into his head and put kryptonite in
there that's why he's sick so Superman
is already out of the picture
the crime syndicate is crime syndicate
arrives with like a big explosion
knocking out everybody basically and
then the first thing they do is they
basically open up firestorms matrix now
firestorm is a superhero who has the
firestorm matrix which allows him to
manipulate any sort of element and
basically go down to a molecular level
and change things so death storm the
evil version of him goes in and opens
that up and sucks everybody into it so
we lose all the Justice League's then
the only people who got away were Batman
and Catwoman at the last second
Wow so now we have no Justice League no
one knows where they are
Justice League of America Justice League
dark everybody has locked up inside a
firestorm and the crime syndicate get
free reign over the entirety of the of
Earth Prime and the only surviving hero
is Batman basically so Batman goes and
he tries to repair a cyborg because the
long story short when the crime
syndicate came through cyborgs
cybernetic bodies separated from his
real body and became its own separate
entity and joined the crime syndicate so
you have like the bits and pieces of
cyborg like injured and whatever Batman
brings his body he starts to get him
repaired and they start trying to figure
out what's going on well Batman has no
answer for any of this stuff so our
events of forever evil then shift to Lex
Luthor Lex Luthor sees all the heroes
gone and he realizes that if the crime
syndicate rules earth prime is very bad
for him because he wants to be the guy
in charge right so he starts assembling
the on the injustice league which is
basically turns out in the end to be
Lex Luthor Black Manta black atom the
the basic black man is
Aquaman's biggest nemesis black Adam is
Shazam's biggest nemesis captain cold is
the leader of the rogues gallery for
flash em he assembles all of these guys
into one group I think there's one more
he has a fit oh bizarro
yeah bizarro and they make the injustice
league to try and fight against the
crime syndicate they eventually team up
with Batman and Catwoman now you have
Batman Catwoman Lex Luthor
black out on Black Manta bizarro and
Captain Cold
and they go to town fighting against the
the crime syndicate cyborg gets repaired
and event eventually the entirety of the
end of the event turns out being Justice
League has to stop the crime syndicate
because Batman's entire focus is freeing
to Justice League he has to get them out
of the firestorm matrix because they're
basically like in a mental prison inside
of the firestorm matrix and eventually
what's gonna happen is firestorm just
going to erupt and kill everybody inside
of the matrix so Batman's whole purpose
is to get them out so the entire forever
evil event is the villains stepping up
to take out this super super villains
yeah and it leads to a whole bunch of a
series of offense in basically at the
end of the whole thing most of the crime
syndicate is dead we have owl man who's
left
he's the evil version of Batman we have
Ultraman the evil version of Superman
that we have superwoman which is the
evil version of Wonder Woman to an
extent but it's actually Lois Lane
she's kind of weird stands on her own I
don't know how that one plays out and we
also find out that Alexandra Luther
which is almost an odd way back to the
Infinite Crisis 1980 series
Alexander Luthor still alive - and he is
the evil version of Shazam which is
weird to the say his name backwards is I
always mess up I I know I did in the
video - it's over I don't know what
makes people come up with stuff like
that like that was one of the things
that was always weird to me like he will
come out with weird names okay but all
right so here's my question so is it no
longer just like Captain Marvel is he
just like Shazam now is that all they go
by because I know there was like a great
big pretty legal battle about Superman
and Captain Marvel I kind of stuff it
well the whole Shazam thing is a legal
battle in itself and eventually marble
picked it up and I think they were still
implying
they call in the Marvel family and
basically it's Billy Batson is Shazam
and then there's the Marvel family yeah
because then kids that you can get his
cousins and friends and they all can
become part of Captain Marvel and it's a
whole whole thing they don't really
refer to him too much as Captain Marvel
but the whole thing is Shazam is
technically just the magic word that
activates everything yeah so yeah do the
show so that's why the terms in comic is
his names right yeah because that's
ethnically and that's the magic word
that activates Captain Marvel and Black
Adam so and they both use the same word
huh all right so so give me the rundown
on Superman these days because I'm out
of touch with like DC Comics itself so
the last the last thing I'd ever really
read because I never really even gotten
like the crisis on Infinite Earths
storyline so what you see you can forget
all about that that's the beauty of the
new 52 so none of that stuff matters
anymore
all you need to know about right now
Infinite Crisis never happened most of
that's never happened Wow know about now
is what I just told you to understand DC
DC rebooted and this is the conclusion
of those three years we've now ended
what we've been building up for this
whole time
so I guess personally I think three
years to build it for that I don't know
if that was worth three years to build
up it was a good good event I don't know
that was what three years of build up
but like I could sit down and start
reading DC now and I wouldn't have to do
like you're like I just have a basic
understanding of characters and could
just pick it up now and just start
reading for the next ten years and I'd
be fine I think today is the issues 31
or 32 and once the series those build
longest-running books in the new
universe you didn't know anything before
that so come on my channel
everyone's like give me the plot of
Final Crisis and I'm like okay but the
first thing I'm gonna do is give all the
events for the new 52 because if you
watch all of these videos you know
what's going on with the new 52 you
could move forward because they until
they reboot us back into the original
timeline this is all that matters okay
these only timelines that stuck around
and it's confusing is the Green Lantern
Tom timeline on the Batman timeline and
basically what they did is everything
that happened to Batman over the course
of what like 80 years ism like that or
75 years whatever that anniversary was
it's now been condensed into a five year
time span which completely confuses the
hell out of all of us DC fans because
that means that he somehow had four
Robins in five years and he's
like 30-something and all these problems
are the 18 which means that he worked
with them when he was like 12 and it
makes no sense that we've all just kind
of said okay we're gonna pretend that
that works we're gonna pretend it's okay
accepted just except to disturb and DC
has said nothing on how this functions
or what exactly happens with this and
the same thing with the Green Lantern
events green lantern and actually is
what am i buying like big pet peeves
right now Green Lantern did so well with
the blackest night that they launched a
dozen different Green Lantern books you
know we now have Green Lantern Green
Lantern Corps which are the two original
books but we also now have green new
guardians we have the red lanterns we've
launched lara fries they're gonna learn
today where they did launch Sinestro and
we have a new new couple more Green
Lantern's coming out of this and I
actually spoke with the writer for Green
Lantern Corps one of the Comic Cons I
went to and he's dead DC doesn't come to
us they let us do whatever we want we're
our own separate entity and you can you
can get that feeling and forever evil
every book got wrapped into forever evil
except the Green Lantern books huh there
were completely separate now Green
Lantern's in the forever evil event but
if you're reading Green Lantern he's
fighting off his own thing in his own
universe and they never seem to
incorporate into anything and that is
the other timeline that has been
unchanged the blackest night and all
these other events have still happened
okay but surely the blackest night
events weren't just like confined to the
Green Lantern himself even if it was on
the planet they haven't revealed how
that works see that's the problem that I
have with stuff like that like they'll
have a great big huge event that'll
affect nobody except for like one person
and yet somehow no one else is affected
by the event is somebody just that one
person but then everything else cross
every book it was on everything
everybody turned into a Black Lantern
and that was the big battle when it
actually happened you know if you go
through Green Lantern and they refer
back to that event still happening but
that's what I'm saying that's what does
it make it convinced in five years and
no one else seems to be aware that they
were all controlled by zombie black
rings at one point that's that's what I
don't get if they come out with a
forever evil storyline and they say that
everything that you've ever read about
all these superheroes has only taken
place in the span of five years as
opposed to however many years that's
been going on for then you know if the
whole Green Lantern history has been
going on for however long Green
Lantern's been around then like how do
you justify that that's that's one of
the things that I that I
that I hate about that kind of thing
crossovers are cool and I love crossover
events because you get to see
superheroes and villains fighting each
other fighting side-by-side that's what
the Civil War was so cool but the
problem is they end up going back and
retconning half the stuff so half the
continuity has changed the other half of
the continuity has not changed and so
you have characters who have technically
been around much longer than other
characters they have backstories to go
on long you know before other characters
and yet somehow they're still kind of
around the same it's its weirdness
convoluted and if you want to know the
biggest convoluted nasai came out of
this whole new 52 reboot and I mean we
probably should go to back to forever II
was that the nougaty reboot was three
years ago at this point but the biggest
thing that came out of that new 52
reboot is Batman is still like 3035 you
know he's still kind of Batman Green
Lantern is still 3035 but Superman who
was in that same age bracket as them has
been rebooted to like early to mid-20s
really so he's younger now he's more
brash he's emotionally doesn't know what
he's doing he's trying to get a handle
on things I actually like this telling
of him better but it doesn't go in line
anymore you know like Batman and in him
were they did there would be the leaders
of the Justice League the older guys the
guys that knew what was going on now
it's just Batman cuz we later never
knows what's going on he always goes by
the seat of his pants so like that's
interesting to me because Superman
always came across like yeah you know
I'm Kryptonian and just by the very
nature that I'm component I'm just wiser
than everybody because unless you
consider like Superboy to be like an
early version of Superman I guess I
don't know much about DC or whatnot then
you would kind of have to a long story
short about Superboy Superboy is a clone
which is a merge between Superman and
Lex Luthor and there's hope in the new
52 C I don't it he's less Superman more
psychic powers okay see I don't know and
I don't know anything about okay
completely destroyed his storyline I can
write about that one for days he's the
most it's they reek ill they re killed
him in the movie Pitou speechless
they've done two big killings in the new
52 since we started
they killed Damian Wayne the current
Robin and they killed Superboy
mm-hmm and they were the most uneventful
just happened by the seat of your pants
you didn't see it coming you're just
dududududu Oh Superboy dad all right
then
like Wolverine we know about six months
in advance you know and then the top it
all off the Superboy story like at least
Damian Wayne he died and every book
reflected it we you know if you wouldn't
reading into it you kind of would have
seen it coming
but the Superboy he died in the middle
of a Superman crossover event and his
book kept going and then in Teen Titans
he was still Superboy but in his book he
was another clone from the future coming
back in time to kill everybody but in
the Teen Titans it's still the the one
we know he doesn't die but in the
crossover vent he's dead look
okay well alright see that that brings
up something interesting because I've
been thinking about that so so to switch
over to Marvel for a second we were
talking about the original sin storyline
that's out right now and we're in issue
number two I think as far as I know yeah
issue number two is the most current one
yes I don't know what comes out today
but before as of tuesday yesterday
there's two issues and one time yes so
alright here's here's my thought here's
here's what I'm hoping for because they
revealed orb to be like the guy behind
it he's the guy holding the eye of the
watcher and I felt really let down
because it's like this big review you
know he pulls the mask off his face and
I kind of assumed it was the or because
it's a mask with one hole in the face so
I was like okay you know so who else is
it gonna be and you know so two holes in
his face huh just had one was it yeah
I'm pretty sure I was I was written to
the comic earlier today and I'm pretty
sure he had a mask you had a hood over
his head with one hole like right in the
center of the hood yeah
I didn't nothing about the orbital until
he was announced in the original sin
event and I had to look him up well it
wasn't it wasn't until you spoiled it
for me when he said like oh is the orb
oops I was like ah what number two but
um but so here's here's what I'm hoping
are so so they're talking about original
sin in there so obviously it has a
religious connotation because they keep
filling out like religious scripture in
the beginning of the comics like Romans
or something like that I don't know but
um what I'm really hoping and this this
is I'm crossing my fingers I doubt it'll
happen but what I'm really hoping is
we'll see the return of Adam warlock and
then we'll see the return of the Magus
and then we'll see the return of the
universal Church of Truth which would be
really really exciting because the Magus
was a really cool character and as long
as Adam warlock is alive the Magus will
be alive because the Magus is just an
evil version of Adam warlock Adam Adam
warlock ism is an old-school care to
Adam well this is why I hope Adam
warlock will come back because Adam
warlock is more or less an Marvel kind
of considered to be like there's a
there's a train coming by the house um
Adam warlock is considered to be like an
allegory for like Jesus and Marvel
Comics more or less well he only pops up
and like the most dire of circumstances
so he popped up during the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline rally everybody
together and said okay we have to find
some way to fight Thanos so he was
really kind of like you know leading all
the troops so you had like all the
pretty much all the earthbound superhero
some superheroes beyond the planet Earth
they were trying to stop Thanos and then
once they failed and the Silver Surfer
failed to capture the Infinity Gauntlet
from Thanos and you had like the cosmic
entity showing up so that's when he
brought in like Galactus and you know
eternity and like all those individuals
jumping into the fray but the Magus
isn't is a future evil version heaven I
think was actually during the warlock
comics there was there's a point where
he travels into the future to destroy
the Magus and in order to keep him from
self from becoming the Magus something
along those lines but any event the
Magus led an organization called the
universal Church of Truth and the
universal Church of Truth was
effectively an organization led by the
Magus where they converted anyone who
either believed in them and would follow
them or they executed anybody who didn't
so it was like the multi-billion or yeah
multiplied billion person Church you
know kind of organization it was
composed of thousands of planets and
star systems it was really kind of crazy
like it was it was interesting but you
know I'm hoping that they bring this
concept back and that we learned that
Magus is the one behind all of this
because to my knowledge Adam warlock
isn't gone forever he hasn't been killed
because the Magus returned even after he
had supposedly been destroyed by Adam
warlock and Adam warlock has returned on
several occasions so I'm hoping that he
simply just kind of hiding in the soul
gym although the the gyms may have been
destroyed but I'm hoping just kind of
lying around somewhere well they were
that's what the time for Captain America
it continued to state they have been
destroyed and that's the time of Captain
America states see a wipe his memory out
and everything I thought that they I
think they I know that after the event
of the Infinity Gauntlet Adam warlock
started the infinity watch so he gave an
infinity gem to six particular people
like he held one he held the soul Jim
and then different people got different
gems like Drax the destroyer got a gem
Thanos got a Jim and their God their job
was to just simply guard the gem so they
could never be brought together again
and used the way the Thanos used them
but I'm not aware that they'd like
physically destroyed them but even if
that was the case you know I still think
it presents a changin overpowered or
like overcharged or something hmm
because they are destroyed right now it
cuz I just started reading through the
Infinity books because I got through the
entire forever evil thing and I'm trying
to do the I'm trying to do the Infinity
storyline to keep to get everyone
current up today on a Marvel on my
channel and I'm reading through the
books right now and the time the
Infinity that the start they kind of
talk about how they've been broken but
going through original said also the
Avengers tie end I think it's Avengers
25 ok the original sent high-end that
where Captain America gets his memory
back if the entire stones incident any
they remember that they were most I
think ones remaining I believe they're
all broken right now except one okay
because basically what they reveal in
that tie in is the fact that the reason
they wiped out Captain America's memory
is because he took all the gems into
himself and was like becoming
all-powerful and throughout his moral
compass and that that's why they had to
wipe his memory he was the one that
wanted to use the infinity gems for his
own personal gain hmm instead of what we
all assumed was the Illuminati wanted to
do it the way the whole book is set up
where basically Captain America shows up
and he's like Oh Tony you worked memory
on what were you guys doing who in the
Illuminati would lost their moral
compass who decided to use these
infinity gems or the one remaining one
or something like that because they
showed them all breaking and then him
holding one yeah I remember that um yeah
so I believe there's one left and then
Tony Stark turns to him and he's like it
was you it was you Steve you lost your
moral compass that's why we had to wait
the memory out but see I thought they
reconstituted all in like I thought they
were all brought back that or not all
they had I thought they had taken the
infinity gems they had destroyed them
and then after the House of M storyline
when all of reality was brought back by
the Scarlet Witch I thought those were
the things that came along with him
because if you remember after the House
of M like there were characters who had
previously met dead that came back like
Hawkeye came back so I thought that all
that stuff had been reinstated and the
infinity gems were back again I'll give
you I could be entirely wrong right here
okay by the way for anybody who's
joining us in this podcast right now or
wants to know we do have a topic list
and basically today we're discussing
forever evil and the fact that it ended
and the current states of the original
sin topic yes those are our core topics
today and at the end of this whole thing
we plan on just because we both give you
a history on characters we're gonna
explain who the heck the orb is because
I don't know but you rob and I had to
research the or so on the forever evil
thing I mean because we just segwayed
right over to original sin to end at
least to the forever evil thing right
now yeah what you were just saying and
this is what I've been telling everybody
forever evil wraps everything up it is
so if and this is what I'm internal is
what I said my opinions video if you
haven't been following DC like you
haven't robbed
don't go try and catch up for forever
evil don't even bother the whole thing
wrapped up all of our plot lines just
start reading everything now okay I'm
considering this a fresh start for DC
again but now we have some trades that
link it now you can go look at the
history if you get really into it cuz
one new 52 hit you could read all the
trades you want but they didn't matter
wherever evil hit we're kind of
restarting in a new direction
like Superman is now fighting doomsday
again Batman is now dealing with great
night we becoming a secret agent or
working with Huntress the flash is
dealing with PTSD which I thought was
one of the weirdest decisions to go with
the Green Lantern's are fighting Green
Lantern clones everybody's kind of going
in a new direction and we basically
started like the equivalent of Phase two
we're like on the next era of DC huh so
okay cool well then in return I kind of
wanted to close that out at least before
we kind of go really deep into original
sin because I got tons of speculation
for reasonable speculate about forever
evil it ended
a few open-ended questions but they did
that on purpose to lead to the next
event which is the anti-monitor the
anti-monitor can eat and absorb the
multiverse the anumana Tercel around
he's back now that was the final panel
of forever evil the anti-monitor is
hunting darkside okay so going through
the universe is the dudas the
anti-monitor
god if I remember the anti-monitor was
one of the most powerful characters in
DC wasn't he yes yes yes I actually have
to verify his moveset he typically
fights with the Green Lantern's cuz he's
like a galactic level one and that's
like a Green Lantern typical thing but
when he comes to the main planet pulling
him up right here to verify everything
but he basically has the he just
swallows worlds is baby much what he
does is from what I've gathered um I
remember him vaguely because basically
he was here for the Infinite Crisis
thing yeah and that and that leads me to
my only speculation coming out of
forever evil are we setting up another
Infinite Crisis we wiped them out
because they were so confusing if we go
back to that I'm just gonna be like ah
did I give up see that's why I like
sticking with Marvel Man Marvel seems a
lot less convoluted once in a while they
come back like they they have a 198
after the house of them they're like
there's way too many mutants let's just
wipe all of them out or most of them out
and start over again which was cool
decided that they made too convoluted a
history I mean for a Final Crisis it's
still rated as one of the most confusing
storylines ever written you know one
knows what happened in that thing yeah
so they reboot it and here it is
anti-monitor basically has devoured
earth 3 and is devouring other universes
on the way as he seemed declaring
Darkseid will be mine so he's going
through universes killing them all
searching for Darkseid hmm Wow that
reminds me of Abraxas did you guys ever
read about Abraxas I know you mentioned
him the other day though okay so I
vaguely remember looking it up to find
where the infinity gems are also so okay
so in in like the mainstream earth-616
like we have we have our Galactus which
is like a humanoid looking kind of thing
he appears different races looks
different ways so on and so forth there
actually comes a point where they
destroy Galactus with the ultimate
nullifier I think and the result is this
being called a Brack sis who jumps from
universe to universe and just
arbitrarily wipes them out like he's
just he's a totally chaotic being
and just arts destroying all these
different universes so what is up
happening is they end up I think either
destroying him or reconstituting
Galactus and I think the lack of absorbs
and absorbs a practice back into him is
something along those lines but he was
he's basically what the universe what
the Marvel multiverse would be like if
there was no Galactus so it was really
kind of interesting because prior to
that point like it had been speculated
that Galactus was kind of like this
intricate necessary part of the Marvel
Universe but you're implying that right
now at the end of age of Ultron
yeah yeah because I remember reading in
an interview because Galactus got pulled
out of the prime universe and placed
into the ultimate universe yeah in an
interview I remember reading about the
ramifications of age of Ultron they're
like yes Galactus is very important to
the universe and him not being here is
gonna cause a problem yeah see I mean
Abraxas popped up he was he was years
ago but but it was it was weird because
up to that point people were kind of
like I mean like Fantastic Four and like
eternity the cosmic entity and they were
saying you know whoa Galactus is like an
intrinsic part you know like he consumes
planets that uh that could potentially
hold life for Celestials and keeps the
celestial civilization in check so they
don't overpopulate you know the universe
and all that kind of stuff but but he
was it was really interesting now all
right the ultimate universe version of
Galactus was weird to me because I know
what you think of him the the prime one
is now in the ultimate numbers okay ok
because they just went through a whole
event I believe it was the hunger ring
or like Cataclysm or something and that
was Galactus going through and
destroying everything oh that's right
that's right that's right
that's right because it's not that
cloudy stupid version yeah because in
the more in the ultimate universe one
the Galactus they had it wasn't even
like a single being it was like all
these little itty bitty things that were
flying around and they were consuming
planets that's right I forgot about that
because uh yeah alright so so here's the
question though if the Galactus that we
have doesn't even exist in our universe
anymore are they going to move back
towards the direction of having a
chaotic universe and even then are they
going to include the idea of Celestials
running rampant because of the basis of
Galactus maybe it is I don't know
original sin I
I'm hoping opens the doors to a massive
event because we already know the
follow-on event its axis and the
assumption is right now is that that
means the Avengers and the x-men are
gonna combine their efforts to stop some
massive force we don't have Galactus the
Watchers dead it's some kind of earth
changing earth-shattering thing and
during that event we know Wolverines
gonna die or at least just before it so
okay but see now that might that might
not necessarily be true though because
the one thing that we both are
universally hated the one thing that we
disagreed the most on was that they made
the watcher like a like a being like he
was an alien basically he wasn't like he
wasn't some disembodied kind of abstract
that just chronicled stuff which I like
that element of them and he was just
kind of you know he couldn't he wasn't
tangible he couldn't be destroyed
he just chronicles stuff and he exists
it out you know who knows what really
needs to go up and say hi exactly like
like during the Civil War the first like
that within the first few pages of Civil
War I might even be halfway through he
appears and I care about who it was but
somebody doesn't know who no it's uh who
was a somebody doesn't know who he is
and Captain America I think he says that
he only shows up in the most dire times
and the fact that yes here means that
like things are gonna go really bad but
nonetheless like I'd like that element
of him being kind of abstract but if the
watcher is now grounded if he was
basically an alien and he could be
killed just as easily as anybody else
that is it really important that he died
is it really relevant that he died
because he's not someone that's so
incredibly powerful that it's almost
impossible to kill him I mean the guy
was shot with a bullet in his eyes were
taken out of his head so it seemed
they've really drummed it down okay and
in my opinion they really did by having
that zero issue and setting him up in
this direction they really jumped down
what could have been a earth shattering
every superhero going oh my god I think
guys by having Nova go talk to him and
then fly back down to the planet and
chat with Tony Stark and and they're
like oh yeah that's just the watcher he
lives up on the moon oh we've been known
about him forever just no one's ever
thought to talk to him I really that
that's the excuse we're gonna go with no
one has stopped to talk to him yeah
all-powerful being who knows where
everything is going and what's gonna
happen and not a single person has said
hey by the way what's your name what's
gonna happen in the next 10 years or or
at the very least like nobody ever
happened to run into him because if you
the Inhumans lived on the blue area of
the moon for years and years and years
and years and years one when he dies
they're just kind of like oh the
watchers dead we should know that that
was disappointing yeah that was really
kind of really pretty much foresees all
the worst events in time didn't see his
own death I would have been like oh my
god I agree I don't know I mean it's
just I see what you're saying and I
really hope that it's gonna go in the
direction of being like a really really
big event like I'm really hoping it's
gonna be something big and exciting but
again you know it'd be different if this
was you know an instance or like you
know yet again we see the Living
Tribunal just laying like dead on the
moon somewhere I mean that'd be kind of
cool you know I mean if they brought
that back but in turn and instead it's
actually something significant as
opposed to just kind of like well you
know I mean you'll come back eventually
I mean if it was some major cosmic
entity you know if like you know let's
say master order and Lord chaos you know
we're laying dead on the moon that'd be
kind of a big deal because now you're
talking about something powerful enough
to destroy a cosmic entity which means
that only a handful of things could
actually do that but now it's just you
know some alien more or less was shot
and it's kind of you know people are
trying to figure out why but see to me
the orb I agree with you guys the orb is
not significant he's not a major villain
in Marvel and I have a very hard time
believing that such a low-level villain
who has a helmet that looks like an eye
on his head you know is one of quick you
don't have to go look at the orb at the
end of this podcast we will give you a
rundown of who the orb is and the reason
why he's important and what Rob is
talking about right now for because
we've kind of it we're assuming people
have read it basically we've had
original sin 0 original sin 1 original
sin 2 and we've had which is basically
the watch has been killed we've been
looking for the killer and what we've
discovered is when the watcher died in
the tie-ins
everyone's getting their memories back
of things that their original sins
things that were so bad they either
forgot or wanted to ignore or that kind
of a thing um in case in point the Steve
Rogers remembering that he was the guy
that used the Infinity Gauntlet which
for the sidenote real quick
I did look it up all the gems are
shattered right now except the time Jim
that's the one that vanished after they
took it from Steve Rogers okay but the
orb shows up and this is all we have on
them so far the entirety of issue to the
orb is talking with a hood on his head
about how he can see things in the eye
is important and they got they need to
try and get away from the superheroes
he doesn't really imply very much but
the ending of the entire issue we find
out that the man with the hood holding
the eyeball is the or about as low list
of abilities you can get this is the
equivalent of Eddie Brock before he
became a venom being a bad guy yeah I
mean this is this is a super low Cup
this this is this is equivalent to
someone like Baron von Strucker being
the mastermind behind all of this some
guy who's a regular dude and was a
leader of Hydra at one point in song
so who's powered I don't know no one
knows they've never said that they they
you know and that was something that
came back way back when you know when he
first received his magical power not
even really magical powers the guy
doesn't really have any powers per se he
has a helmet it looks like a giant high
because his face is disfigured and it
helps them see but in terms of like
actual amazing I don't think the helmet
helps them see I think the helmet is
just he wears the doesn't seem like it's
on a tear that it would be of any
importance to the whole universe
okay his power is that helmet which
we're still unclear if it's still a
helmet or just a giant eyeball on a head
now that's the biggest question that I
have at the moment because are we
sticking with the helmet because that
makes him even more z-list
anyway yeah and he can shoot lasers yeah
he's not a significant character I would
say eye lasers but no he's not important
I mean you you've got you've got really
really big characters you know like for
example juggernaut gets us
hours from city rock you know I mean
you've got some characters out there you
know that exist in other dimensions
Dormammu and Doctor Strange there's some
really really powerful beings out there
from other dimensions and I have a very
hard time believing that the
end-all-be-all
the big figurehead and the one guy
behind all of this is the orb and if it
is I would be so disappointed by Marvel
to find out that the orb is the guy that
is behind the whole thing because as I
understand they still don't know who
actually killed The Watcher it's just
the orb has this eye in his hand now now
what well that's what they better do
because you have to look at this from a
competitive standing with forever evil
for everyone just ended and you know if
you're trying to find it
so basically forever evil we have the
crime syndicate the evil version of the
Justice League is our core villain they
are all-powerful all-knowing they killed
the Justice League and in Marvel we have
a guy with an eyeball helmet thank you
all right here's here's the thing here's
one thing to keep in mind all right
and I hate heaven I hate I hate keep eye
coming back to this all the time but it
really it's a reoccurring theme in
Marvel the House of M all right after
the House of M storyline there are some
characters that pop back up again that
were either as powerful as they were
before or more powerful so it's entirely
possible the orb is that's true the view
inside of the house well it affected
superhumans of it you couldn't even pick
a dealer's villain from like Captain
America or it's the guy that was in
Captain America 2 in version 9 you know
no it's he's a guy who was in Ghost
Rider has Ghost Rider ever really been a
big entity of the he doesn't even cross
over yeah intercourse on fear itself
maybe well but he's a soloist he cam use
the crossover I'm talking mostly I said
you saw a ghost rider in a crossover
where he was a core element yeah I mean
I understand what you're saying
girl in cricket and like rolls then I've
seen Ghost Rider outside all right I
understand what you're saying like I did
I get what you're saying I mean he's not
a major guy but you got to keep in mind
man I mean a lot of stuff changed after
the House of M I mean we have we had the
198 we have the Terrigen mists which
were being given to people we don't know
how far Quicksilver got with the
Terrigen Dumas because if you remember
after the house of him you had the son
of him and knew had Quicksilver who
stole the Terrigen mists from the in
humans or the Terrigen crystals rather
from the Inhumans and started giving
people the Terrigen mist to try to bring
their powers back and sent them into
overdrive there was a really cool shame
or what came out of house of em yeah
yeah even growing came out of Wolverine
taking over the school kiddin come out
of the house of amber there's some stuff
to keep in mind too even now like during
the inhuman event like you still have
the Terrigen mists that's that's
expanding all over the world and so
those people who were in humans and were
differ were part of different factions
other than the ones that we saw in the
actual inhuman comics I mean they're
they're developing abilities they're
they're changing they're becoming you
know what the Inhumans become when
they're exposed to the Terrigen mists
now we don't know what the orb looks
like under his helmet all we know is
that it's just the orb and he's got the
eye of the watcher in his hand so we
don't really know what the ramifications
are it's entirely possible that the orb
ascends from in humans he was never
exposed to the Terrigen mists because
he's inhuman
and he has been exposed to the Terrigen
mists now it's entirely possible he's
gonna develop powers I would think that
if he was he probably would have used
them by now and it may very well be the
case that he was the one that killed the
watcher by using the powers he developed
from the Inhumans but the problem is
that when it comes to in an inhuman
developing powers after the Terrigen
mists is to throw the dice they don't
know what they're gonna be they have no
earthly clue the inhuman Jean activates
they evolve and go from there I just I
just found out something because with
the way this wiki for him it because
he's such a Steelers character his wiki
sucks his 2009 Ghost Rider Heaven's on
fire 1 & 2 appearance not happening
but there's two orbs and one of them is
a guy with a giant eyeball for a head
mmm he uses a ray gun now going off of
what you're saying there maybe he's a
mutant although I would I would I would
kill to God of the moons if my power was
my head turned into a giant I'd be
pretty pissed off like there's a Raygun
um I don't know I mean that's that's one
of the crazy things because I think that
one of the things that people have a
habit of doing is I see a crossover like
like original sin and they focus only on
the original sin but there's all kinds
of stuff that's going on you know in
Marvel Comics now in addition to the
original sin storyline I mean the one
thing that we see all the time with
Marvel and I'm not sure this happens
with the DC is that Marvel writers will
sit down and they'll say okay we want to
have a major event that's gonna start
and you know January of 2014 and so
virtually all the comics belonging to
characters and teams that are gonna be
part of that event starting in like the
beginning of 2013 will start to segue
that direction they'll start to segue to
that center point and then once that
event starts and notices be crossovers
and tie ends but the comics will pretty
much all revolve around that event until
the events over and then they'll split
back off and do their own thing again
and so when you have something like the
inhuman event where you have all these
different things going on when you have
something like the infinity event that
ended not too long ago where you had
Thanos who was hunting around for his
kid you know you had like all these
different things that were going on and
it's not entirely out of the question
that they're all not directly tied in to
what's going on with the original sin so
I you know two issues and or three
issues then I guess out of eight it's
really difficult to tell but but
apparently Bendis took as ILA's villain
and made a like is the prominent villain
in some kind of recent event and the
guys thinking that the guy that my comic
book store thinks that this is an
attempt to do that again with the org
but with not Bendis writing it you know
man I'm gonna tell you something
what event had a c-list villain take
over though I can't remember what he
said it was not fear itself there was
some other big event that just happened
that it turned out some some surprised
guy was behind the whole thing and he
was something like obscure villain a
newer event
yeah I was something that recently came
by it was a Bendis event me Michael
Bendis maybe gonna find it out well
let's go through my hundred and seventy
gigabytes were the comics and see about
that I mean that'll the atom was three
generations of x-men man he rates way
too much stuff Avengers vs. x-men was
infinity who was who was who was the
mastermind behind infinity
that was that was Thanos it was a fan of
us but he wasn't the mastermind that
started the event he just took advantage
of the event well I thought he was the
one that started it maybe I haven't got
enough around the comics maybe he did
right from what I'm seeing so far he's
just taking a banner because the the pre
lewd the pre Liu - it is Avengers 14
through 17 and Brian New Avengers issue
number eight and then it picks up from
there and then it starts with an
infinity issue number one and then it
spreads throughout the Avengers Mighty
Avengers New Avengers each the
Thunderbolts was behind siege it was
that was no that was that was when I was
born invading Asgard I thought yeah I
think the Thunderbolt sir yeah like
anti-heroes yeah and New Zealand
replaced the Avengers with his own
Avengers right and and you tries to take
over Asgard yeah I'm reading that we're
not gonna find this on the podcast but
there is a story which came out of
nowhere it was the guy behind it and I
guess everybody loved it and that's
that's what that's what my guy at the
comic book store I think they're doing
with the orb now bear in mind everybody
we're only at issue two for original sin
so if you listen to this in like six
months and whole events over yeah don't
be too rough on us but those things
though is because it's like there's so
much speculation they can go on here I
mean in the end like we only know two
things two major things one the orb has
the eye of the watcher and the Watchers
dead so you know we have no real idea
what's gonna be going on here now what
I'm really hoping fingers crossed at the
end of all this is that Richard writer
comes back now whether that'll actually
happen or not I don't know I mean I
don't know that
many obscure guys man super obscure
Richard Ryder I don't know they might be
trying to shoehorn a little too many of
these obscure characters in there when
every comma bug reader has to go
who's the orb that's a slight issue
there we need some kind of recognition
with this guy well I mean I don't mind
the idea of obscure characters
characters popping up in comics I mean
you know that's something that I enjoy I
mean for example mad rocks you know
Jimmy mad rocks multiple man I mean he
shows up in civil war but he's like you
know doesn't have like a major role and
he's just kind of there he's you know
anti-registration but bringing back
obscure characters like I don't know
what they say and I don't care how many
of you people like Jessica drew the
Spider Woman shows up everywhere and I
can't find anything where she matters
not really always like it's like the
Avengers do everything and I'm still
here
well okay indirectly she serves a big
role during The Secret Invasion because
if I remember she is cloned by the queen
of it where she's uh she's copied by the
pleaseplease
they're a part of it behind the scenes
you know like yeah she's there I I've
read a lot of Avengers guys a lot of
Avengers x-men a lot of crossover events
and she like never prominently pops up
it's always just like hmm we need a
female to level off the team right now
tomorrow is Spider Woman well okay but I
mean take for example like the age of
Ultron like how significant was it
really that Susan storm went back in
time with Wolverine I mean it wasn't
even her the convinced Wolverine to I
mean it was Wolverine they convinced
himself like Wolverine from the we don't
need Sue Storm Richards whatever she is
now from the future and in this
alternate future blehh blehh blehh blehh
blehh oh and this one's on a microscopic
level they just went on vacation on the
hair of a dog I mean I don't know I
don't know what they're gonna do with
this whole original sin event but what I
will say is that if all this turns out
to be the orb as the mastermind behind
this event I'd be pissed I'd be really
really pissed off because unless
huh now with the right writing that
could still turn into something epic now
I agree with you right now but what if
it turns out that the Orem has behind
the scenes manipulating everything and
like they give you like how it all
pieces together where and they've been
dropping hints forever and this is been
something they've been setting up now
how they doubt it but this is this
something that they've been setting up
for ever and you've just missed it and
it's so epic it is so amazing I would
believe that if it was a Chris Claremont
story but it's not that would be he's
getting controlled by an a-lister
incredible 7.1 he didn't even get into
like a full issue of the Hulk it was
just a random guy yeah there's got to be
something bigger going on here at least
I hope there is because if this is it I
mean this is you know if what we see
here is pretty much gonna be the
remainder of the story the Orbis is
doing some crazy stuff and people are
like what in the world is going on I'm
gonna be really lazy something that we
haven't brought up at all yet though one
the orb has one eye that's a good point
that is a good point I didn't even think
about that where is the other odd
because it took that is a good point man
alright okay so alright let's talk about
this alright let's talk about this let's
talk about this so where's the other eye
okay who could all right
we've been harping on the orb now for
like thirty minutes we haven't once not
mentioned there is another I rob the
truth okay then who would have the other
eye I stand by my statement I I mean I
still stand by my theory that Angela's
gonna kill Wolverine cuz he's the one
that pulled her out during the age of
Ultron of it but I doesn't like do it
for Aaron Wilson unless unless unless
unless hold on what if what if Wolverine
soon as we find out that he blew up the
timeline everyone goes to kill him and
we find out that the second eyeball is
being held by like Cyclops adult Cyclops
cuz you always doesn't specify that
because there's
nine of them that's stupid or what if
Thanos has the other eye what is
somebody that matters has the other eye
then the question is how did the orbit
this the second one hey Thanos buddy you
mind if I take that squishy thing I
wonder if they gave it to doctor string
or Doctor Strange has it I know he has
the eye of agamotto I think that's what
it's called but um no because Doctor
Strange is in the issues he's going to
try to figure out what happened yes sir
he is trying to figure out what have
another watcher no he's not he's in
seclusion
he went with Punisher into like some
corpse realm huh okay is that a tie-in
because I don't know all four that are
out right now I don't know which is in
which okay I need to read that tiny
missing Avengers I've read that time yet
yeah no I see Man Punisher they're like
some alternate world right now trying to
figure out because I guess some like
great beings have died in some alternate
universe music why am I here why am I
here yeah he gets asked to go over there
and it's like an ongoing joke why is he
here Doctor Strange can figure out
everything and then dr. strange misses
the most obvious that the monster was
shot with a bullet
okay okay me and Dave had this
conversation the other day I was telling
about this guy you ever heard of a guy
named Matt Jim Jasper's okay I changed
all of all of the reality around it yeah
he could he could warp reality alright
they need to rename that guy that's an
awesome name I don't know what you're
talking that's an awesome name if if
madam jaws purse is coming back that
would be an amazing no I mean no no I'm
not throwing our crazy speculation let
me tell you some man I am very happy
with pulling random Uncle Ben's coming
back woman's been warping reality for
the last like 70 years like he's been
there little time just nobody knows
the last rule we used to have the rule
that went on forever Buck Rogers was it
what was it Bucky Rogers can never come
back from the dead
oh look but garage is it back from the
dead Bucky Rogers who you're talking to
me Barnabas it was three people that
were never allowed to come back in the
dead till they came back from the dead
yeah Bucky Barnes maybe was I don't
think it was Dick Grayson who was the
second Robin no no oh yeah Tim Drake Tim
Drake and yeah Uncle Ben is not allowed
to come back do not break the law store
that car do some man spider-man fans
would be pissed the photo bin comes back
I'm waiting for that I'm waiting for
issue number six no okay I'm not I'm not
drawing random names out of a hat I am I
am we are I am I am I am NOT drawing
names out of a hat
Mad Jim jasper's is one of the coolest
villains in the history of Marvel Comics
I've got a shaker bottle right here oh
my god alright now you guys just being
obnoxious I'm saying I'm just saying I'm
just saying Mad Jim jasper's is a great
villain and how he can warp reality he
was an omni versatile threat he was a
threat to multiple realities and I think
it'd be awesome if he had just like if
you could pop back up again how many
guys can we use oh we're gonna go with
the orb okay that's like 10 points off
of your skirty list here yeah and those
those ten points are gained back plus
some if mat Jim Josh was the one pulling
the strings you can't have the entire
thing is being run by Zeile a super
heroes or villains who have not been
around
last ten years no uh no no sir it's
entirely possible to have that oh by the
way we seem to have miss the fact that
mad Jim Jasper's came back and organized
every crappy villain and gave them
eyeballs to go play with him oh well I
mean the guy's crazy so you know say
he's mad mad Jim Jasper little I'm just
I'm just pulling stuff out of my ass but
everybody who's listening is podcast
because we can go on for a while about
this then what do you think do you think
Rob is right do you think it would be
awesome to have another crazy obscure
care to come in do you want to see the
or would be behind everything or do you
want to see like some major bigwig
suddenly step forward like issue four or
five and announced that it's him behind
everything no no let's quantify that and
say that Matt Jim Jasper's is obscure
but he has the ability to warp reality
he can warp reality he can change
reality as he sees fit so just keep that
in the back of your heads when you're
deciding who's right me or Bennett is do
you think it's my theory that it's dark
claw behind everything or David's theory
that it's ambush what is your theories
on the direction that they're gonna take
the original sense series we're only two
technically issues in one tie-in one pre
lude so there's so many directions that
this could go at this point I mean the
fact that they even exposed the orb it
throws us for a loop it to begin with it
and started all of these discussions
maybe this is Marvin was going for it
maybe it will be mad Jim Jasper's up to
that and then issue four would be some
other obscure gaiden issue probably some
other obscure guy that we find out it's
Thanos controlling all of them yeah I
mean you're right I mean it could be a
massive event because we only do have
one tie-in but I mean we've seen events
I mean Age of Apocalypse was a pretty
lengthy event it was 80 some odd comics
and it wasn't a super okay they used to
do that like they live that with Age of
Apocalypse so like they would have on
the back like the checklist you know for
stories well that's disappointing twenty
years
well there's eight main issues and I
think it's two to three times per month
first month they better be a good 20
issues gonna be very mad at us or just
kind of like the big reveal like Captain
America getting his memory back and you
know I believe in spider-man we're gonna
find out that somebody else was bit by
the spider in the original sins were
gonna find out where they went what
happened you know maybe it's maybe it's
Majumdar it by reality-warping spider I
don't know yeah I take that spider it'd
be pretty cool but so well I mean so
basically every we're just running on a
thousand one different tangents and
theories and ideas at this point and and
pretty much rob is gonna fight to the
end of a end of the earth that it's
magic Jasper yes sir I will fight it so
the end of time that is dark cloth and
you'll be wrong they're bringing back
the Allegan hologram I don't he came to
say whatever that universe was the
merged universe we're getting back man
it that's what the original sin is the
original sin is that they dissolved
everything we're bringing it all back
I'm all taking to that Marvel bought the
rights to ambush bug we got Angela back
and it was like yeah oh yeah yeah that
spawn girl from like 20,000 years ago
yeah that chick from spawn I don't know
I mean either either way no matter how
it happens I'm kind of glad let's see
I'm on the fence about Marvel doing
crossover events because I think the
problem with Marvel doing crossover
event I think you and I talked about
this before Benny was that they do it
just because they can you know that's
become the thing and they all of them
are doing the math the only people not
doing the crossover events is image and
that's because they just don't produce
enough comics they produce too many
individual comics and I'm not a big
enough like big event commie they don't
cross anything over yeah but like even
DC DC okay do you see got delayed on
forever evil and they've already started
a new one so we've already got like
three issues into futures end and we've
got forever evil was still wrapping up
like you or you started the next event
and you didn't finish the last one yeah
I don't know I mean see here's where I
think Marvel kind of screwed up way back
in the day like way wait
today you had those early Marvel comics
that you had Marvel team-up so you had
Marvel two and one you had you know
strange tales tales Asus pants all that
kind of stuff those those were stomping
grounds I mean you could show up on
Marvel's door knock on the door and say
I want to do comics and they'd say okay
fine go over there do some stuff and
we'll see what happens and if you're if
you're popular then we'll throw you into
sand the Fantastic Four if you pick up
and Fantastic Four will give you your
own comic that was that was the formula
for Marvel back in the day and they got
away from that like they walked away
from that they got rid of those for the
most part they try to bring him back but
they were short mini-series they were
less than ten issues and they you know
they do but what I'm saying
Cyclops some all new x-men just got a
miniseries yeah but but there's a
difference
like I mean when a when a person's like
Cyclops is a Maine kid he's a mainstay
he's you're right young for the all-new
x-men but alright but I mean like
Cyclops has been established no matter
how they do Cyclops if it's ultimate
Cyclops if its all-new Cyclops if it's
Cyclops from battle of the atom which is
just the all-new Cyclops you know if
it's regardless of who it is it's
Cyclops everybody knows who's Cyclops is
he's an established character so if a
rider shows up that doesn't know what
they're doing they're gonna say what's
this guy doing this guy's screwing up
one of the best characters in Marvel as
opposed to some newly created character
or some super obscure character like the
orb they can kind of give him some comic
on the back shelf that you would
probably never see in Marvel Comics and
just say write stories and we'll see
what you do but the problem here is the
comic I quit mark my words is was gonna
have it if the orb is the center of this
whole thing with original sin then the
original sin event is going to come to
an end and they're gonna say yeah it
would be silly but but I don't know I
mean it's you know crossovers are cool
crossovers were kind of fun but
crossovers were better when they were a
rarity because I don't want to buy a
Marvel comic all the time and see like
it was like once every couple of years
exactly now we literally have them twice
a year at this point
you know we thought we were not even
finishing up when we go into the next
one yeah we just keep rolling through
these things at this point there they
hype each other up I mean forever evil
ended by hyping up the anti-monitor
which apparently supposed to be two to
three years out and also opened up
futures in like how are you opening up
multiple crossovers at this point yeah I
mean I prefer you know just you know
keep them separate you know have amazing
spider-man you know because we have we
have like Peter Parker back as
spider-man now so how did like amazing
spider-man have Peter Parker doing his
own thing in a solo comic bring back
Captain America and have them do his own
thing as his own solo comic you know
yeah but it's not necessarily like a
used to because now yeah but now it's
always like Captain America is part of
the Avengers if you remember you had
Captain America in strange tales I think
it was yeah but what I'm saying is he
appeared as a side as a side item to
another comic then he had a solo comic
then he appeared in The Avengers and his
solo comic came out periodically and
then he was part of the had his own solo
comic which maintained up until the the
Ed Brubaker run from volume 5 and then
kept going which is when we saw Winter
Soldier come back but I want to see him
have his own solo comic and see Avengers
really kind of become like a semi-annual
thing become like a quarterly event as
exactly movie every year if they wanted
to but instead they're they're doing
they're doing the Avengers like they're
supposed to be done they're being broke
just like the Justice League just like
x-men like the core group they're only
really supposed to be brought together
for these big events that requires
everything exactly I'm because if you
reflect for the longest time you have
the golden blue team of x-men I mean you
had to split into two factions so you
know to me that's that was one of the
great things like like the Avengers have
their own comics that was cool and went
on and on and on that was interesting
and it was a great way because Hank Pym
never had his own comic I mean you never
he was never like a like an individual
running solo he was always him in in the
Avengers you would have like a 20 year
lead up to him creating Ultron I mean I
don't know what you would do like I
don't yeah I don't know what you would
do with Hank Pym in his own comic so it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be fascinating
so we got to see him in his own
do it because there's a whole solo story
he becomes uh the he goes crazy no I
thought that was part of the Avengers
storyline because that was the second or
third return of a man or of a Ultron the
guy that's the guy who stole everything
you're right I don't think Henry Pym has
had his own ya know Hank Pym ever had
his own solo comic yeah I was gonna say
yeah it was uh it was um oh god I should
know this Lang was his first name Scott
Lang yes it was Scott Lang's own comes
that's when ant-man got his own kind of
thing going on but nonetheless I mean
like I want to see a return to
characters for the most part of having
their own storylines you know ant-man
can appear every so often or whoever it
is a skin that's running in the Avengers
now like they need to really kind of
like establish the core group again and
have them run their own original thing
like I haven't you know go around every
you know four months or something like
that and have a release of the New
Avengers but I want to see a return to
older comics I want to see these
crossovers go away being such a constant
I know they're not going to this point
but what adventures did okay the nerd
culture and geek culture in itself you
got to go back to Whedon beginning it
with with Buffy and all that Buffy and
Angel started the the giant massive
crossover stuff that brought geek
culture to the prime things like Firefly
and stuff like that started to build a
little niche the groups but then Big
Bang Theory as much as I hate to say it
really made it mainstream no it did it
did
merged geek culture and humor into
modern-day mainstream comedy and made it
okay to really get involved in all this
stuff and basically based on a Big Bang
Theory the comp Marvel took the movies
and the fact that they were picking up
steam and Big Bang Theory can hide
things up started doing Iron Man which
then led to a giant crossover movie
which then turned into the Avengers
movie event which is then turned and
then on top of that you've got shows
that came out of the Whedon era with
Buffy and Angel such as lost and we're
gonna do an enjoying attire show which
is seven seasons of one plot it's all
we're gonna do things like alias started
this up and this all came out of the
geek culture now the geek culture has
overtaken everything else in reality
prep pretty much everywhere you got
things that came with Thrones you know
my mom watches Big Bang Theory and lost
like my mom Big Bang Theory and she's
trying to get the jokes okay
I never got in The Big Bang Theory who's
playing the Marvel Avengers of something
or other her Facebook game and was
telling me that his mom knows these
characters because of that game knows de
Marvel characters not the movies because
Marvel is on Facebook now let me tell
you let me tell you something man as
long as Marvel's popular I'm okay with
it as my channels gonna keep girl know
like you you are you are 100% right with
that what everyone has discovered
especially with the age of digital
download so if you miss an episode of
your TV show you can just go download
the episode in this day and age people
want to see giant universe continuities
giant things coming together giant
projects that you feel like you're
awesome cuz you know everything about
that right now I've just made a video on
my video game channel it goes out today
about how watchdogs and Assassin's Creed
are apparently in the same universe
Ubisoft is making the ooby verse they're
like mark rise that's good watchdogs are
all in one thing like everyone is doing
this now everyone wants to cross promote
their products through and they've
discovered that this is the one of the
most ingenious marketing tools ever
because if I really like this and you
take the time to mention something
that's why they do these crossover
events yeah why do you think an original
sin every avenger showed up to fight the
the orb and then we got the orb the orb
of all people why me you know why do you
think they bring up all these obscure
superheroes because those obscure
superheroes you're not gonna see in
something rather be like well that was a
really cool guy let me go get that book
I mean don't get me wrong it was it was
cool to read original sin in the scene
Nick Fury and Wolverine Wolverine people
keep giving me hassle because of how I
say Wolverine to see Nick Fury Wolverine
and Captain America sitting at a table
eating together I mean that's cool
you know that cross what element is cool
but how good can a crossover story be if
those are the only stories that we're
getting
I mean crossovers were meant to be major
events there
to be things that were lawful in size
I'm pretty sure that's why they've
started going in the direction of cuz
forever evil did it I know original sins
doing it infinity did it where they're
coming out with their own core book to
the event we're back in the day the core
event would just run through one book
you know it'd be like hey spider-man for
the next ten issues is gonna be about
maximum carnage enjoy yeah you know the
Avengers is gonna be about the secret
war for the next ten issues enjoy
now it's here's your court book and what
you see is a lot of the other books just
keep going like normal now this creates
our continuity errors because it's like
how the hell was Green Lantern fighting
all these clones when at the same time
he was trapped in the firestorm matrix
or you know how is Wolverine in twenty
different events in books and what are
you again I show I showed you the image
of the joke or Wolverines entire week is
pretty much doing something yeah and
that's what these continuity errors come
out of and I think that's why they're
now doing okay well if you like Captain
America he's in the infinity event with
Ironman and random Avenger number three
and guess who's getting his own book at
the end of this that's pretty much it
and if you just keep cranking these
things out
you keep cross promoting your universe
and you keep getting more product out
let's see to me I would prefer less
crossovers and great stories as opposed
to consistent crossovers with mediocre
stories because of the problem with
because and this is definitely something
you can see Bendis is kind of he's kind
of tapping the bottom of his creative
barrel at this point yeah you know these
events are starting to feel kind of
dragged out and drawn on in like okay
guys like how many times are we gonna
have like an earth-shattering event I
think that's my biggest complaint why
can't we have a giant crossover event
that doesn't end with the end of the
world that they fail you know and and
see here's the thing like solo comics
allow characters to grow all right Edgar
Baker's run of Captain America many
considered to be probably one of the
best runs of Captain America because you
saw more character development of
Captain America during that run and you
had seen in a lot of previous years but
when you have major crossovers you see
the established element of a character
existing in that crossover they don't
necessarily grow as much as they would
I'm pulling the reins on Rob I'm yanking
Rob we got to calm down about the
crossovers another day and if people
want to hear that we could easily hit
that under the next
like let's let's discuss the orb real
fast for the next ten minutes explain
who the orb is give them some history of
the orb and then we'll wrap this up for
the first episode and see how people
think and get their opinions okay
sound good sounds good to me okay you're
not gonna yell at me no I'm not gonna
yell you seem like you could get very
angry and like your head goes on fire
and you get like a skull thing going you
could look like the Ghost Rider into an
excellent segue the orb is originally a
Ghost Rider villain the orb is actually
Madame Gaspar's in disguise the original
orb is named Drake Shannon and he was
born in West Virginia he was a
motorcycle stunt rider and he owned half
of the traveling motorcycle stunt show
that would feature Johnny Blaze who
would become Ghost Rider alright the
other half of the show was owned by
blazes mentor crash Simpson basically
eventually as time moves on he becomes
like he's the evil version of the owner
you know they always got the one guy who
just wants the money and does all the
stupid stuff well he does the stupid
stuff and he gets horribly disfigured
trying to do some crazy stunts to sort
out of the way of hitting crash Simpson
whereas after many miles of neck-to-neck
competition
Shannon deliberately swerved toward
Simpson in an effort to force Simpson to
crash the other mentor of Johnny Blaze
okay and he basically the maneuver
caused him to crash in his figure his
face so after that for reasons unknown
according to the wiki pretty sure
there's probably some obscure comic back
in the 70s came out that explained what
happened but for whatever the reason he
was given a motorcycle helmet by the day
who will power which was looks like a
giant eyeball and gave him the ability
to hypnotize people and shoot one giant
laser and it is that point that he
became a Ghost Rider villain okay
basically he goes through a long series
of things so that a bit of fighting
against Ghost Rider and it takes go
shirt and spider-man to eventually team
up and defeat him permanently from what
I've gathered through here he seems to
pop up against spider-man occasionally
on the spider-man get all Ziva's
villains at some point is that just how
it works uh spider-man did spider-man
it's cool but he's just not that
powerful I mean aside from carnage
doesn't really fight you know in his own
comic some major villains like solo up
against the ultra honor
he got incinerated I think an age of
Ultron so he has a continued over uh
like a rivalry against the Ghost Rider
he eventually crossed his passive
Hawkeye has to fight Hawkeye that
there's another guy who really can't do
much else other than fight like Z
Lister's
he appeared in Marvel team-up number 14
I think yep yeah 15 that was his first
appearance okay
it was first appearance was November
1973 and Marvel team-up number 15 well I
was close he has been seen fighting
against uh was it he fight alongside
black out dead deaf ninja and dog head
and he was killed by the caretaker
according to black out although we don't
get to see it actually happen he pops up
periodically to fight against the Ghost
Rider then we had a second orbit
takeover hmm um the second orb doesn't
actually talk at all pretty much from
what I'm gathering he doesn't seem it's
like a very rare occurrence and he
actually is a giant eyeball on his head
with a Raygun hmm although I'd even
state sit in here
he has never successfully hit anybody
with it maybe actually an eyeball um
outside of his like initial return as a
second guy he's been seen in the
background of most issues
he's a background character who doesn't
even get a name at the time yeah just
the eyeball guy is pathetic and then he
appears in the astonishing spider-man
Wolverine miniseries robbing a bank he
seems to be robbing diamonds but he
eventually seems to gain the
understanding of time-travel because he
was out but he was stopped by Minutemen
Minutemen Minuteman I thought Minuteman
was one guy I don't know I'm not
familiar with Minuteman yeah um but
before before he could use his time
travel knowledge and abilities he knows
that a time travel he can't use it
basically the new orb the one who
doesn't talk it isn't actually a big
squishy eyeball he then fights against
the Hulk and red she-hulk cuz that
probably ended up well for him and he
can end we discovered that he can see
into people's eyes and see their entire
history so he knows who Red Hulk and red
she-hulk are due to that maybe that is
tied in to the whole original sin event
maybe makes sense and then according to
this the orbs latest appearance is
Marvel's 2014 event or
in issue number two where he is shown
having one of the Watchers eyes hmm orb
seems like he could be the guy I think
in looking at people cause you see their
whole history getting more powerful like
that gaining powers like time travel and
you know seeing in the people here's a
mystery though is only seventeen issues
total um its bands over Marvel team-up
he's in quite a few issues of Ghost
Rider he pops up in the Incredible Hulk
he's in solo Avengers 19 and 20 and
Avengers spotlight he's in some book
called deadline never even heard of that
one and he pops up in the astonishing
spider-man Wolverine series one through
six huh
so he's primarily a Ghost Rider villain
and he also fights against Spider Man
O'War and Hulk Ryan look up his history
there's got to be more to it than this
but he's so obscure that it's so it's so
little on him you know man if those guys
don't stop mowing grass out there man my
god don't put on your hey let me I need
to get a Houseman I hate living in the
Bartlett complex
all right yeah I mean I look up the
history of the orb I guarantee my
subscribers are gonna screw me to V
about him sometime this is all I was
able to Drudge up the first time I could
hey the second port see let's even get
more information on him yeah definitely
I don't like using websites like Comic
Vine but I guess I have to I'm in the
same way I like reading most of the time
and reading a story and then what I do
is I go to the wiki's to verify a lot of
my facts cuz yeah we always miss stuff
yeah but I like reading through it all
myself but I can't I don't he's the
orbit they updated his cut his a Marvel
Wikipedia to the original sin thing here
it is he was born he was born with the
head of a bull in the form of a giant
eyeball due to this deformity he was
abandoned at early age and raised in a
freak show sometime later he became a
mercenary and served the
the angel zag Creole along with a death
ninja dog head and black out during an
attack on the caretaker the former
advisor to catch the orb accidentally
damaged his own eye how would you damage
your own eye you have one giant eye one
job to do when he triggered a trap
inside of the caretakers home launching
a wooden plank into himself the horde
was then taken to the prison hospital
where he survived and had treatment due
to his trauma he then escaped from
prison thanks to deacon and blackout who
wanted him to serve zack riyals
task force of Ghost Rider phones along
with him and the new Vengeance along
with them in the new vengeance alongside
vengeance he attacked the gateway to
heaven and faced the gun nuns ok I read
that comic and was not to help by Daniel
catches Ghost Rider so here you guys
better build what this is still gonna be
a stretch no I mean it's not gonna be a
stretch at all like there in the current
events in the 8th issue of the new
Incredible Hulk series he robbed a bank
and took the eyes of the workers and
then when he left he saw Betty Ross and
the Hulk fighting and said he would take
their eyes as trophies yeah that's where
you can read into their history and he
finds out that she's just trying to get
her approval and huh so I mean we're
learning about these characters were
doing it but we're trying to give you
more in depth under these individual
characters at my opinion he's still a
Crabby super villain yeah that guy sucks
you know there's much better super
villains to pick them in I don't know
I'm not really sure how this is gonna
turn out but regardless I mean looks
like it might be kind of interesting I
guess we'll have to wait and see how the
original send story progresses but he
looks fine over here in the original sin
but then if you look at him in his
original appearance is he looks like
every turn
it looks like the Ben Stein commercial
guy he really does just no way how it
feels when you poke your eye or throw a
rock at his eye and it'll hurt a lot
because it's not listen as he was born
with this deformity is this I'm will go
is it is there a medical condition where
you medical condition
giant eyeball let me tell you something
you go find something like that in the
Philippines or something see some weird
stuff out there there's a giant eyeball
thing called the giant sell author okay
wait I even in this picture it is not
one giant eyeball just I don't I don't
understand how that works but I didn't
even what we need to wrap this podcast
up guys yeah yeah we've been going off
about an hour and a half or so with a
couple interruptions here and there but
not too bad not too bad for our first
podcast I don't think we're just gonna
blame Rob it's always gonna be Rob's
fault David might as well it's all good
so everything can go back to him
everything can go back to me it's all
good I don't mind but uh yeah guys so
make sure you check out our channels I
mean you got comics story in binney's
channel it's a sub channel of eligible
monster and of course I'll always be a
link to his video to his channel at the
end of one of my videos and of course
they don't make sure you check out my
channel Marvel explained this will be my
channel so if you're watching this over
on my channel are the links to
everything Rob does will also be in the
descriptions of my videos from this
point on now that I caught on that he's
been doing that for a couple days for me
it's so good alright guys well uh yeah I
guess I guess we'll call it a channel -
yeah what's he missing once he makes one
alright guys we'll catch you guys later